hello everyone and welcome to a most
wonderful game from round five of the
costume of Memorial now I know this is
already the third game were showing from
from round five but we did say it was a
very vengeful round and it's just a
great game between Alexandra Grisha and
former world champion Veselin Topalov it
features a not and not even often played
line of the Queens gambit declined and
well you'll just have to see what
happens so without further ado let's
check it out
Goethe shook has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 we have Knight to f6 c4 e6
and as we already said Knight to f3 and
d5 the Queens gambit declined is on the
board Knight to c3 with Bishop e7 just
the standard line Bishop to f4 by Griff
shook and now castles by T'Pol
we have III I'm just preparing to
develop the light square Bishop Knight B
to d7 and now Bishop to e2 and here D
captures on c4 finally as usual in the
Queens gambit the client only after
white develops the light square Bishop
will you capture on c4 and make white
waste a temple
we have castles now comes c5 attacking
white strong center D captures on c5
Knight captures on c5 and only now
Bishop captures on c4 and here at the
pile of plays b6 it's a new move in this
position which is very odd for the
Queens gambit declined having already a
new position at move 10 as you all know
the Queens gambit decline is one of the
oldest openings in chess we've been
covering a lot of it during the kosaka
but you know most more more often than
not a black will have problems in the
Queens gambit the client how to develop
the the light square bishop and here at
Apollo already solved that so what's the
problem with this align a line of play
with black well let's see how the game
air continues we have Queen to c2 now
what is does have some Lydian
development but that's perfectly normal
Bishop to b7 to power places is light
square bishop on this beautiful diagonal
we have rook F to d1 now as the Queen
vacated the d1 square now the rook
occupies it it comes with an attack
against the black Queen we have Queen to
c8 and now comes Knight to b5 this is
what Greek had in mind
this seems to be well the downside of
this line for black now in the early
development of the bishop the light
special because now Knight to d6 it's
coming where you will either win the
light square bishop or black will have
to give up the dark square bishop if he
wishes not to leave the night on this
very nice d6 square so here we have a
six attacking the knight Knight comes to
d6 and here topologist grabs it with
Bishop captures Bishop captures and now
rook to d8 and rook a to c1
I just with a nice rook win battery
along the C file night with night c2 e
for by black just a nice knight on e4
and now comes a bishop but back to
before offering a trade of rooks along
the D file top all of trades we have
rook captures Queen captures and d1 now
the rook is eyeing that Queen and c8 so
top our moves it nuts the d8 he moves it
all the way to be eight and here we have
Russia back to e two we have looked at D
eight now attack English shocks Queen
Queen to b3 and now butter up to d5
attacking the Queen we have Queen to a3
attacking the a6 pawn and here just a5
and the bishop goes all the way to e 1
and here you have the bishop on e 2 and
the bishop on e 1 algoriphagus forced
the tuck away has better prepare for the
moments to use them later with a much
deadlier force with h6 by top all of a
nice useful move taking away the g5
square from White's Knight also making
some breathing room for the king and
Knight to e5 now by Gary shook we have
looked the c8 b 3 now the Queen now
guards the rockin c1 and also the B 3
blocks the light square bishop so the a
2-point will no longer remain a target
so a lot of purpose to the b3 move we
have route captures and c1 Queen
captures on c1 and now Queen to b8 have
a threatening to capture the knight on
e5 also may be preparing to push on the
Queen side and here you have a position
where well the material is completely
equal but white still has the bishop
pair if white is able to utilize the
bishop pair then everything well it
should be a little bit better for white
as the game is played on both sides of
the
or the position is pretty open so the
bishop should have an advantage here you
could play an F for seems like a very
nice chart move but it does weaken your
III pawn and well yeah all in all agree
she decided not to do it he decided to
take care of the night differently Queen
to be to display now defending the
knight we have nice the c5 now by black
and here f3 just you know would further
control of the e4 square e 4 is probably
gonna be played and also making room for
this bishop to come to g3 once the
knight on e5 is attacked
we have night f2 d7 now top allah wants
to trade night and now butter up to g3
and just putting that - upon this very
nice diagonal also protecting the night
queen to c8 now getting the Queen out of
this nasty pin and now comes Knight to
c4 here agree sugar I guess the night
out of the way he doesn't want to trade
he's putting a lot of pressure on the
Queen side you can put both b5 you will
lose the a 5 point and here it's just an
unpleasant position for black so here
the pallav decides to give up even the
light square Bishop with Bishop captures
on c4 Bishop captures on c4 and now
Queen to c6 so now it's two bishops
against two nights where again at the
place on both sides of the board and
it's a pretty open position so the issue
does have the advantage with with the
bishop pair here we have Queen to e2
just a nice centralizing square for the
Queen
we have f6 by black and the now comes
Bishop to b5 pressuring the Queen end
the night after the Queen moves Queen to
d5 and the now Bushra back to c4 n-tuple
repeats rush of the Queen to c6 it's
very hard for T'Pol to look for
advantage in this position so of course
he does not mind repeating moves
especially with the black pieces and now
Grisha retreats with the Queen Queen
back to be - again with a nice idea of
centralizing the Queen with Queen to d4
also he might have ideas of a3 before in
the future we'll see how it goes with
King the f7 a top all of the sides now
it's time for the team to also enter the
game h3 and now comes Knight the b7 just
Rema nuvaring Queen to d4 centralizing
the Queen for white and now
came to e7 and you know there's the
thing that you can have an active King
but you can also have a too active king
and the too active King is not something
you won't have so here a Grichuk
immediately tries to take advantage of
this he was king a queen to g4 with
ideas of infiltrating the king side so
King has to go back we have King to f7
and I'll just came to h2 improving the
position of his own King and here you
might want to go something like 95 with
an attack on the Queen and the Bishop to
at least to grab one of the bishops but
here it doesn't work the tactics work in
white's favor just captures captures and
queen a5 check the pawn of course is
pinned you cannot capture after the King
moves now you go here threaten the g7
pawn and if you defend it too then you
get Bishop captures and the white should
be why should be able to win this
position so after King to h2 we have
Knight d2 c5 by black and now comes a3
just preparing before now we have g6 by
black and now comes before a capture Sun
be for a capture Sun before and here you
can see that black is in a lot of
trouble because what do you do with the
knight the problem is if you move the
knight let's say you go Knight to d7
feel free to pause the video and try to
find how white wins here and what's the
problem with moving the night I'll give
you a couple of seconds to decide
whether we want to do it or not
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
winner of games and for those who just
want to enjoy the show
b5 is the move and now you can see that
the Queen has no squares left from where
she can defend the e6 pawn the bishop is
controlling all of the dark squares here
so that's not an option the bishop
controls d5 the queen would have to move
and once you move the Queen
you just get Queen captures on e6 check
King g7 Queen f7 King g7 Queen f7 check
King to h8 and now just Bishop to b5
however you are threatening too much
black black has no moves the Queen
cannot move has to keep an eye on this
night has to keep an eye on this night
if you move the Queen anywhere out of
the the back rank you will get Queen g8
checkmate if you try something like
anything anyone would like to say g5
didn't get Bishop c4 you still can to
defend
made you have to go something like this
and then just the Queen captures night
black black will fall apart here so you
cannot move the night what do you do
here first you force whites to move the
Queen with h5 now of course the Queen
has to move we have Queen to f4 and only
now nice to d7 so now there are no
threats of capturing on e6 Bishop to e6
Mogadishu and again it's a a very
interesting move because if you play a
slow mood black let's take into g7 you
get Queen to c7 and Queen to c7 is
winning for white because well you're
either gonna lose lose a piece here or
if you capture White will recapture and
then the knight has no squares because
the bishop is covering both d8 and d6
and the point is covering a5 and and c5
so the knight would be trapped here this
is the idea I agree she has with Bishop
d6 now comes Knights to d8 getting the
right I mean there's there's there's
that threat a threat and also the threat
of Queen in for infiltrating via Queen
to h6
but you can stop both of them so Topalov
prevents any loss of material with night
to d8 and then out comes Queen to h6 and
now Knight to f8 preparing preventing
Queen to h7 check but this should be
back to d3 and again there are a lot of
threats here for example you could
capture on g6 and after Knight captures
just Queen h7 check B comes back pick up
the knight on g6 in the win some and win
a pawn but also it's it's very
unpleasant for example if you play
something like Queen to c3 it's even
worse let's say Bishop to d6 now you
don't really have a good defense against
Queen captures on f8 which would be
checkmate and well there's a just
nothing you can do here so after Bishop
to d3 we have f5 not allowing this this
to ever be a threat now comes see for
Greece shock now wants to bust open the
Kings side completely Queen to d7 going
after the bishop and now Queen back to
e3 the Queen did all look we needed to
do on the King side so now back to the
centralizing squares we have Queen to c6
and now Queens the d4 Topalov still
wants to trade Queen d7
squint to see three and g52 Paulo hopes
of closing up at the position with f4
but of course agree shock isn't
interested he captures he captures and
now Bishop to c4 check and here again a
very difficult position for two Paulo if
you go King g6 Queen h8 and it's it's
very unpleasant for example if you go
king - Queen g7 just captures captures
and Bishop c7 will win you the b6 point
and you have to move the knight now
comes captures and after the bishop
moves this pawn will just march forward
and and should win the game so after
Bishop c4 check we have night dte 6
blocking and now Queen to h8 all the
same King to g6 by top olive and now
Bishop to e5 with ideas of not data but
with ideas of coming to f6 width check
so queen t7 defending and now Queen to
g8 check Knight to g7 blocking and now
Queen back to d5 so it's a it's it's a
tough position for 2 Paulo not a lot of
active moves Queen to d7 top olive still
in hopes of trading Queens and now
Bishop to d6 blocking and also preparing
to capture the night on f8 so we have
Knight f back to e6 and now just Queen
to e5 getting out of the way and waiting
for black to make a move we have h4 by
top olive as it is the best move there
are no other moves and now comes the
Bishop to b5 leaving the black Queen
with even less squares to choose from
Queen to c8 still just trying to keep
everything together and now Queen back
to d5 and here the pallav goes Queen to
c3 a nice a nice active move with the
Queen with some ideas of going Queen e1
Queen g3 check on and maybe retreating
to Queen Queen e1 and hoping for a
perpetual check here which could ensure
him a draw but the Greek isn't
interested Queens Bishop to a check and
of course you cannot capture if you
capture you will lose both of them after
a queen captures with Czech Queen f6 now
you don't capture the night but right I
mean you do capture tonight because it
comes with Czech and now of course after
he moves you will just be up up a whole
piece
so after Bishop e8 check we have kink
the h7
and now comes Bishop to d7 again with a
double attack against the night here and
Queen to e1 and okay for the moment the
bishop is guarding the g3 squares so
there aren't any problems here and also
the queen is now guarding the night here
so you cannot capture but again there is
a one move that you know allows whites
to push for the win and again feel free
to pause the video and try to find this
move I'm just gonna have a nice sip of
water for for those of you who found
that congratulations you are an
excellent blocker of Queens and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show Bishop e5 now Bishop captures
Knight is a is a very serious threat so
it's not all that clear how you defend
this but top ala finds a way he plays f4
and of course it's an interesting idea
now if Knight is captured the bishop no
longer controls the g3 square black can
draw this with a perpetual kim jiwon
Queen e1 checking each one Queen g3
check back and forth and it will be a
draw by threefold repetition so not
something really she wants to allow as
he is still hoping to win this game
Queen to d3 check and now it doesn't
matter where the King goes blacks next
move or White's next move is pretty much
the same King to h6 this is the best
reply for black and I'll just brush it
back to c3 allowing Queen to g3 check
but it doesn't do anything because the
Queen will have no squares to retreat to
the bishop is not controlling a1 so
Queen to b3 against Apollo wants to
trade Queens but Queen to c4 just you
know continuing with the pressure King
to g6 and now push up the c6 with ideas
of going it over to e4 King to f7 by
black and now comes Bishop to d5 again
putting immense pressure on this pin
night and here we have nights that I ate
and here a gray she was rush of the d4
he attacks the Queen and it's a very
interesting idea of course if the Queen
moves and then you get Bishop captures
you just grab a grab let pass pawn move
the bishop and start pushing your past
pawn there's not a lot of white can do
here even if you go for Queen G to be
check King h1 Queen e1 check now the
visual retreats and the
no further checks now you just push her
past one to victory so here after Bishop
to d4
- Paul tried b5 now you know if you
capture my queen I'll just capture your
queen but goody she said no thank you he
played Queen to c6 and it was in this
position almost 69 that Veselin Topalov
former world champion resigned to the
game
what if you resign well there's really
not not much you can do here now you
could say play something like Queen
captures on d4 although it doesn't help
you all that much because after Queen
captures an e6 you will go King to g7
and now of course you don't capture the
night because then a la Queen captures
Bishop first you go Queen to f7 check
and now if King to a traitor then Queen
to g8 is checkmate you have to go to h6
and now of course you all see the move
Bishop to e4 and now there is no more
stopping checkmate either Queen to h7 or
Queen to g6 will be checkmate the only
move that prevents both of them is Queen
to g7 and now after Queen comes to g7
you just capture the night and you are
up a piece and in a completely winning
endgame yeah the pole did not wait for
this after Queen to c6 he resigned and a
wonderful victory for Alexander great
shock and his and his aggressive pair so
to say and if someone would have missed
my yesterday's video so we did show -
nice games here are the standings after
round 5 Carlsen still in first place
with three and a half then Anand and the
Carrick in with three then with two and
a half Dingley Randolph Navarre
Alexander we shook after this in the
very nice victory and Timur a job of
Sharma media of and Veselin Topalov now
with two points and onigiri in last
place without a single victory and
already with two losses which is like I
already mentioned you know something
that happens very very not and I don't
know it don't even remember when when
was the last time he had such a
tournament and he was just about to
re-enter the 2800 club but you know
that's chess you know things happen sir
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it's really really an impressive
game showing how to really use the
Bishop prepare against anything
when there's an open board and when the
the plays on both sides of the board so
a very nice tutorial by Alexander
Grichuk I would like to thank William
Miller the only fly singer
Jose Sanchez Stephan Miller and Jeff
graves for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check too on my
previous video so your thing called for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content you know do usual and of course
checking up on your suggestions I think
you'll I will see you soon heaviness
have an excellent rest of your day